vigilance équidés c'est le nom de la
convention qui a été signée mercredi 30
décembre dans les écuries du poste à
cheval de saint nom la bretèche entre le
monde équestre l'état et la gendarmerie
objectif assurer la protection des
chevaux après la vague de mutilation
d'équidés de ces derniers mois c'est une
première nationale et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est de voir là qu'on joue
la conjugaison des efforts de tous le
secteur privé des centres équestres des
éleveurs des militaires avec la
gendarmerie nationales la gendarmerie la
garde républicaine
donc c'est fini une innovation mais ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est la conjugaison
de nos efforts pour protéger les équidés
dans le département cette convention
vise à créer un réseau départemental des
changes et de solidarité entre forces de
l'ordre et monde équestre
pour ce faire 15 référent et quittant
seront répartis sur le territoire
i'm all ce sera emma bataillon le rôle
en fait c'est de faire le contact entre
les différents acteurs donc notamment
gendarmerie pour faire remonter
l'information le plus vite possible et
agir en cas de en cas d'événement ce que
l'on ne souhaite pas bien sûr les
yvelines n'ont pas été choisies au
hasard pour être le premier territoire a
signé ce nouveau protocole de protection
quinze mille chevaux et plus de 800
propriétaires c'est le premier
département équestre d'île de france et
il comporte aussi deux unités de
gendarmes à cheval
les missions de ces deux unités sont
assez classique ça nous permet encore
une fois donc de faire ou du contact du
renseignement avec la population et puis
évidemment donc d'avoir eu des relations
très particulières avec le monde du
cheval d'une manière globale donc les
centres équestres les haras et puis
naturellement on a donc au travers ces
deux mythes et l'a donc une action très
résolus et offensive sur tout ce qui est
atteinte à l'environnement d'une manière
générale c'est beaucoup plus simple
parce que les gens viennent beaucoup
plus nous voir et il nous donne beaucoup
de renseignements qui ne n'aurais pas
forcément donné un véhicule et en armure
et en plus des 15 référent et quittant
un guide va aussi être diffusé et des
panonceaux affiché pour aller encore
plus loin dans la sécurité